we're seeking feedback on several topics
in this year's draft annual plan
the rangiora airfield is an important
facility for the district and one of the
busiest public aerodromes in the country
the council needs to meet new
legislation for its management and to do
this we need to upgrade security the
public water supply sewer network and
areas of the runway
we also want your feedback on upgrades
to the popular ashley gorge campground
and reserve the council are responsible
for supplying its water and to meet the
drinking water standards for new zealand
new equipment is needed so that we can
monitor and test the supply making sure
it continues to meet the water standards
to keep people safe
finally we're proposing to make
improvements to a funding structure that
supports landowners to protect areas of
native bush wetland and dry land
ecosystems
this change will better recognise the
size of land being protected and more
equitably encourage landowners to
protect these special areas for the
future
we'd love to know what you think about
these proposals find out more and have
your say at waimakariri dot govt dot nz
forward slash let's talk